لا تحجب الشمس جمله نسمعها في السينما او
في الشعر والسياسه احيانا لكن هذه المره
تستخدم في العلم
وبمعناها الحرف في ضمن الهندسه الجيولوجيه
الشمسيه هي احدى الافكار العلميه لتبريد
كوكب الارض بتقليل اشعه الشمس عنها في
سبيل مكافحه الاحتباس الحراري وقد امر
الكونغرس الامريكي بتطويرها في مارس 2022
بل ايضا عارضت منظمات بيئيه تمويلها
بملايين الدولارات هي في الاساس تقليد لما
يحدث عندما تدفع البراكين الجسيمات الى
الغلاف الجوي فتسبب غمامه كبيره تبرد
العالم بشكل ملموس الان دراسه جديده
نشرتها صحيفه عن مقترح لنشر كميه مهوله من
غبار القمر لصناعه غطاء خارجي حول الارض
يحجب عنها اشعه الشمس لفتره من الزمن
تفاصيل هذا المشروع العلمي المناخي مع على
سرحان
في يونيو عام
1991 ثار بركان جبل بين طوبو في الفلبين
ادى ثورانه الى اطلاق اطنان من الرماد
والغاز صوب الغلاف الجوي ما اسفر عن تبريد
الارض بنحو نصف درجه مئويه بكل تاكيد الهم
التجربه البركان الفلبيني العلماء ورجال
الاعمال الكبار وفي مقدمتهم بتمويل مشروع
يتمحور حول اطلاق بالون ضخم ينشر غبار
الطباشير في طبقه
لتعتيم الشمس بالقرب من مدينه كيرونا في
القطب الشمالي هناك طروحات مغايره لحجب
الشمس تقوم على استخدام مراوح عملاقه يتم
تثبيتها على سطح القمر لاطلاق الغبار
لبقعه تتوسط الارض والشمس ليصنع من هذه
الكميه من الغبار درع حامل للارض هناك من
فكر في اطلاق الرماد بمنجنيق او تشكيل سور
من المرايا او الالومنيوم لعكس اشعه الشمس
اما الرافضون يعتقدون ان هذه الافكار
تلاعب مع البيئه
وستسبب تلويث المحيطات بالغبار الكبريتي
وقد تسرع من سيناريو تحويل الارض الى جليد
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على كل نفهم اكثر ينضم الينا من عمان عمار
مجاهد الخبير الفلكي وزمير الجمعيه
الفلكيه الملكيه البريطانيه اهلا بك
يعني لمكافحه الاحتباس الحراري يتم تعتيم
الشمس لتبريد الارض اصطناعيا عبر الهندسه
الجيولوجيه حدثنا اكثر عن هذه التقنيه
يسعد صباحكم شكرا جزيلا انا الدكتور عماد
مجاهد وليس عمار فقط
بالنسبه تسلمي بالنسبه لهذا الموضوع حقيقه
هو موضوع يفكر في علماء الفلك والطقس
وبالذات وكانت ناسا من عقود في محاوله
لتقليل الاحتباس الحراري هلا احنا منعاني
كمان معلوم في كوكب الارض في ارتفاع معدل
درجه حراره كوكب الارض هذا ادى الى حدوث
التغيرات مناخيه معروفه هو مالوفه للاسف
منها ذوبان المحيط
ذوبان المحيط عفوا وايضا ارتفاع الحراره
في القطب الشمالي وذوبان الجليد وايضا
انتشار الاوبئه الاوبئه والامراض الان
عفوا العلماء عم بيفكروا انهم يستخدموا
طريقه معينه بحيث يقللوا من معدل درجه نصف
درجه هلا بال 91 كما جاء في التق
اثار بركان في الفلبين وادى الى انخفاض
معدل درجه حراره الارض في مناطق معينه سطح
الارض بحدود نصف درجه ولاحظنا في تلك
الفتره ما حدث في الشرق الاوسط والخليج
العربي وكانت حرب الخليج الاولى عباره عن
سبع سلجات في الاردن والشرق الاوسط وكانت
نادره جدا السبب كان الغاز ثاني اكسيد
الكبريت والكربون اللي اطلقوا بركان
الان علماء ناسب ضيق الوقت
وياريت هيك احنا نبسط الامر للمشاهدين هل
احنا يعني كانه بدنا نتغدى بالاحتباس
الحراري وقبل ما يتعشى فينا يعني بدنا
نتحايل عليه انا افهم بهذه الحاله طيب كيف
بدنا نتحايل عليه وشو بس بطريقه مبسطه يا
ريت يا استاذ عماد
هلا احنا في في دول العالم وعنا في الاردن
في الارصاد الجويه
استخدمنا تقنيه
الاستمطار يعني انه احنا نحلب الغيمه بما
معناه يعني الغيمه لما تكون جايه فوق مثلا
الاردن او ابو ظبي او اي بلد وكانت هاي
الغيمه غير جاهز انها تمطر ممكن نعطيها
مواد كيماويه وبالتالي بصير مطر الان
العلماء بفكروا انه نعمل
ننفذ بغلاف الجوي للارض ثاني اكسيد
الكبريت لما بنعمل هذا الطبقه بصير تبريد
في المناطق اللي صار فيها
تبريد وهذا التبريد ايش يعني انه احنا
ننزل او نقلل من معدل درجه حراره كوكب
الارض بحيث انه نزيد كميه الامطار ونزيد
من البروده في المنطقه اللي احنا في هذيل
الخليج العربي الشرق الاوسط شمال افريقيا
او امريكا او اي منطقه
الهدف منها تخفيض درجه حراره احنا هدفنا
مكافحه الاحتباس الحراري بعد فشل كل
الجهود في ذلك هل هندسه المناخ قادره على
عكس الاحتباس الحراري يعني تبريد الارض
على مساحه واسعه يعني نتحدث عن مساحه
شاسعه من الارض وبشكل الدائم على مدى عقود
هل بامكان ذلك
والله اعتقد التجربه لا زالت نظريه هي
مطروحه نظريه ولكن هل تم تنفيذها حتى الان
يجد العلماء صعوبه في ذلك يعني بصراحه غير
متفائلين للامانه لست متفائلين هي عباره
عن دراسات نظريه موجوده مطروحه وتم يعني
طرحه عالميا وفي هناك خطه انها تتنفذ
بربين
ولكن هل ستنفذ هل هي فعلا سيكون لها نتيجه
ايجابيه لا احد يعلم حسب النتائج اللي
ستقال في رافضين من البدايه لهذا الموضوع
بيقولوا لك اذا اذا بردنا النصف اليمين
مثلا من الكره الارضيه الجزء اليسار من
الكره الارضيه
سيتضرر سيتغير بطبيعه الحال المناخ فيه
كيف ايضا تقيمون هذه النقطه وحتى في مخاوف
من اثار اخرى وتداعيات لها
احسنتي احسنتي هذا السؤال السؤال مهم جدا
عفوا نعم صراحه يعني لما نستخدم ثاني
اكسيد الكبريت في في غلاف جوي مثلا فوق
دول عربيه ستتاثر دول افريقيا او شرق اسيا
واذا ما عملنا ثاني اكسيد الكبريت في
امريكا ممكن تتاثر بلدان اخرى ايضا يؤدي
الى تلوث ثاني اكسيد الكبريت ممكن يكون
غسان ويؤدي الى اثار سلبيه على البيئه
يعني لا تظنوا انه المشروع صالح مئه
بالمئه وانه لن يكون له تاسيس سلبي بالعكس
هناك عدد كبير من علماء المناخ ومنهم
وكلاء وكاله ناسا خالفوا ضد هذا البحث
احنا كل حاله بنشكرك جزيل الشكر للحديث
دائما ترتيبنا بهذا الخصوص من عمان عماد
مجاهد الخبير الفلكي وزميل الجمعيه
الفلكيه الملكيه البريطانيه شكرا لك